Okay, folks. I'm going to get started.
Um
your quizzes are ready to be picked up.
So, when you get a chance, please do
pick them up.
They are in alphabetical order still I
checked when I left and I hope for
hopefully they would still be in
alphabetical order
when you go and look for them, right?
So, today we're going to you know,
continue our discussion of capital
structure. Before I do that, though,
I have to tell you that um
after I called Derek Kevin on Monday,
the Yankees have been on a losing
streak.
The reason this is linked up is didn't
you say you were named after Derek
Jeter, right?
My favorite Yankee. So, since I couldn't
name my favorite I'm very superstitious.
You know, I exercise always in numbers
that add up to five. 32 minutes, 40 My
wife thinks I'm crazy, but you know, it
it works for me.
So, today I will call Derek Derek and I
will start today's session with a
question to Derek, right?
Which is we were talking about banks
towards the end of last session. We were
talking about
how do you determine whether a bank has
too much or too little debt and the
reason we couldn't come to a conclusion
is why can't we compute whether a bank
has too much debt or too little debt,
right?
And but why is it that debt to a bank
becomes this amorphous mess? Why do we
treat bank debt at banks separately from
debts at every other company?
Because debt to a bank, it's like
nailing Jell-O to a wall, right?
Technically, when you put in a deposit
in a bank, does it have the
characteristics of debt?
Fixed rate deposit, you know, you have
contractual If I start defining that as
debt, a debt ratio of a bank could be
96, 97, 98%. Since you can't nail down
the debt, we turn to the other side and
say, do you have enough equity?
So, I'm going to start with a very
simplistic example today to kind of
illustrate what I mean by, you know,
looking at the equity.
I'm going to start with a very simple
bank, a bank that is actually a bank.
An old-fashioned bank. What did
old-fashioned banks do? They collected
deposits and they borrowed money They
lent it out at a higher rate. They made
money off the spread. Their primary
business was giving loans to people,
businesses, individuals.
So, let's say you're a bank with 100
million in loans outstanding. That is
your asset. You've loaned them out.
And that you have book equity and for
the moment, let's assume that's also
your regulatory capital, your book
equity of 6 million. So, your regulatory
capital ratio is 6%.
You're a growing bank, though.
You expect the loans you're going to
give out to go from 100 million to 150
million. Why? Because you're in a
growing part of the country. You're able
to give those loans out.
And you want to increase your regulatory
capital ratio from 6% to 7%.
So, let's think about what's going to
happen next year, right? You're going to
go out and you're going to make 150
million loan and that's what you want to
do. 7% of 150 million is 10.5 million.
That's how much equity you need to have.
You have only 6 million.
You need to get from 6 million to 10 and
1/2 million. And I want you to think
about all of the ways banks can increase
their equity.
What's the most organic way to increase
equity at a bank? What should you do?
How does book equity go up?
Why does book equity change from year to
year at every company?
Branch?
Retained earnings, right? So, if you
make net income and you don't pay it out
as dividend, that is critical. That goes
into book equity. So, if you have 4 and
1/2 million dollars in net income and
you don't pay dividends, that'll get you
from 6 to 10 and 1/2 million.
That's going to be quite a reach.
Let's say you can retain only 1 and 1/2
million.
So, you get from 6 to 7 and 1/2 million.
You got to raise the extra 3 million in
new equity. So, if this bank says we
want to grow, what do we need to do? I'm
going to say, hey, as long as you can
grow, great, but you have to raise 3
million in new equity by either issuing
shares or, you know, figuring out, you
know, rights issue, something to bring 3
million in.
That's what growing banks need to do to
keep up. So, to grow as a bank, you need
to increase equity. To increase equity,
if you have retained earnings, amazing.
That's great. But you say, look, I don't
want to issue
new equity.
Then, as the bank, what do you need to
tell them? You got to bring your growth
ambitions down. You can't have your cake
and eat it, too. If you want to grow,
you got to raise your book equity. Of
course, this is a very simplistic
example. It's a very simple bank. Let's
take a messy bank.
Take Deutsche Bank.
Deutsche Bank at the and this was in
2013 had an asset base of 440 million.
Banks have this very special way of
classifying assets. It's called
risk-adjusted assets. So, basically, it
comes from how regulatory ratios are
defined. But think of it the total
assets they have and their regulatory
capital ratio was 15.13%.
Now, most of that that's tier one There
are three tiers regulatory capital. Tier
one, tier two, tier three. Tier one is
almost entirely book equity. It has to
be pure equity or very close to equity.
So, they have equity. Let's call that
tier one capital of 66.15 billion. So,
that's where they are right now. 439
billion dollars in assets, 66 billion
tier one capital.
Let's say the bank is targeting getting
to 18%. Why? They're feeling a little
nervous. They're getting losses. They
want to build a buffer.
To increase their tier one capital to
increase from 15.13%
to 18%, their tier one capital has to go
from 67 billion to 92 billion. That's a
lot of additional capital that they
need.
Now, of course, to the extent that they
have net income, some of that can be
covered
if they pay no dividends, right?
So, basically, what I'm trying to
compute here is how much can this
company pay in dividends? I'm going to
return back to this concept later when
we talk about dividend policy
because that regulatory capital has to
come out of your net income. And if you
look at the bottom line there, the
amount of regulatory capital they will
need over the next five years is so
large that if they ask me, how much can
I pay in dividends? My reaction is you
can't pay dividends. You're in the hole
already.
But the problem was
Deutsche was paying dividends and they
wouldn't stop. We'll come back and talk
about why banks in trouble continue to
pay dividends. It's insane in my view.
Cuz when you pay dividends, what are you
doing? You're already undercapitalized.
You're not using the opportunity of
using net income to buffer your capital.
You're paying it out as dividends and
then you go out and issue equity in the
other side. The only people who are
happy when you do this
are the people you used to issue the
capital because they can make money on
it because you're paying out money on
one side and paying and and raising
equity at the same time.
So, if you get a chance, take a look at
the top 25 banks, you know, S&P, they
report their tier one capital ratios.
You can see which banks are
well-capitalized,
which ones are, you know,
okay-capitalized and which ones are
undercapitalized.
Cuz ultimately, every bank needs its
regulatory capital. And why do
regulatory capital authorities require
banks to hold regulatory capital? What's
the What's a What's
What is the basis for it?
What do you want to do? Branch?
It's not If it's a bank, banks don't go
bankrupt, right? Banks actually get into
enough trouble, they've got to be taken
over. Why can't you drive a bank into
bankruptcy? What?
In fact, we If you get a chance, go back
and look at these old photographs from
1929 and 1930. Remember, there were no
regulatory capital ratios. You see these
long lines outside banks.
Were those companies waiting to pay
their loans you think waiting in line to
pay their loans? It was depositors
wanting to get the cash out. You get
bank runs. I mean, a bank run is
terrifying because it takes the entire
economy down with it. The reason we have
regulatory capital is because banks will
have shocks to the system
of people not paying their loans, a
trading loss. You need that buffer so
that you don't go into deposits because
the last thing you want banks to do is
using deposits to meet these
requirements because then you have bank
runs.
So the That's So but regulatory capital
is actually relatively recent to
banking. It came out of the Great
Depression.
Were there banks before the Great
Depression?
Yeah, absolutely.
How were they run? They were
self-capitalized.
The Rothschilds ran their banks for 500
years and guess what? They learned
through through through experience, you
needed regulatory capital. You needed
that capital buffer.
So you can almost say that even if you
remove the regulatory overlay, if you're
a sensible bank, you would still
self-regulate. You'd set aside enough
equity because you don't want to run out
of money when you get that shock.
Of course, since 1930 across the world,
regulatory capital ratios came into
play.
So there are banks that look at
regulatory capital ratios and they try
to meet the regulatory capital ratios.
It's like taking medicine for them.
And you know what happens when you treat
the regulatory capital ratio as just
another rule?
You play games with it.
That's exactly what banks did leading
into 2008. How do you play back How do
you play games? You take riskier
investments and you're describing to the
regulatory capital authorities. They let
you have lower regulatory capital
because they're missing the risk.
But what's the downside of the strategy?
There were riskier activities you're
involved in, right? Risk is a real
thing. You can't make it go away. So
when that risk hit 2008, you effectively
found that most banks did not have
enough capital. Royal Bank of Scotland
had to be taken into receivership
because they didn't have enough capital
to meet those demands.
So if you're a bank, you can stay with
the regulatory capital minimum, but
you're playing a very dangerous game.
I think you actually have to combine
regulatory capital minimums and some
degree of knowing your own risk and
saying, "You know what? We're at the
minimum, but we're going to build a
buffer on top of it."
If there's a lesson that banks should
have learned out of 2008, is this isn't
a game.
This is your survival. You can fool the
regulatory authorities and get away with
it in good times, but there will be bad
times and you need to set aside enough
capital to meet it.
I hope banks
are well capitalized now. It looks at
least from the outside that they are
because there will be shocks coming in
the next year
from borrowers not being able to make
their payments because a trade war is
going to have casualties. There are
going to be companies that are unable to
pay. And if you're not capitalized,
you're going to feel the pain.
Any questions about bank capitalization?
And so whenever you talk about a bank,
focus on equity because to bank, it's
only equity capital.
So we've talked about
five regulated companies in a bank.
We've talked about optimal debt ratios.
I want to step back
and ask the question, why do optimal
debt ratios vary across companies?
Because even across the companies we
looked at, Disney had an optimal of 40%.
Tata Motors had an optimal of 20%.
Vale had an optimal of 30%.
And Baidu had an optimal of 10%.
You're saying, "Why do the optimal debt
ratios vary across companies?" And this
is going to be the framework you'll be
using in your project to talk about why
the optimals vary across your companies.
Because you have five companies in your
group. One of your companies, the
optimal might be 0%.
And there might be another company in
the group where the optimal is 60%.
Let's think about the framework that's
going to try that's going to help you
explain why those optimals vary. First,
remember the biggest benefit of debt
is the tax benefit.
There's a marginal tax rate you can
enter and you get an optimal debt ratio
based on that. For Disney, it was 40% or
close to 40%.
For Vale, it was 34%.
But I actually played a little game. I
said, "Let me keep all of the other
numbers fixed and just change the
marginal tax rate
higher or lower." So if I take the
marginal tax rate and make it 0% for all
of my companies,
magic happens. My optimal debt ratio
goes to zero. But really not, right?
It's the it's intuitive that if I take
away your biggest benefit,
you shouldn't be borrowing money. If you
have a marginal tax rate of 0%,
you shouldn't borrow money. Doesn't mean
that companies won't because they might
choose to do it because they don't want
to issue equity. They don't want to give
up control. Across the Middle East, the
marginal tax rate in many countries is
0% and across the Middle East, there are
companies that choose to borrow money
still.
And you say, "Why would they do it?" And
the answer is because they don't like to
give up control. These are
family-controlled companies. They will
choose to borrow money because
you know, they don't want to give up
that control.
You know, among the lowest tax rate
companies in the world are the cruise
line companies.
If you get a chance, take a look at
where all of them are incorporated.
They're not incorporated in usually in
Miami. They're going to be in Bermuda
They're going to be in Panama. They
Basically in in parts of the world
where the tax rates are really low. And
here's the game they play.
I've been on one cruise and that'll be
the last cruise I'm on. Most boring
thing ever, right? You're stuck on a
boat, nothing to do except eat yourself
to death, right?
So you get on the cruise actually about
for the first 30 minutes after you leave
port, nothing happens. And then
magically, all kinds of things show up
that you can pay for.
You know why? Because you've left the
You Technically, they're selling you
stuff in the high seas. Nobody can claim
that this is their national
jurisdiction. They can claim their
income then
in Panama wherever the tax rates are
low.
So if you look at the the the effective
tax rates for these companies, three,
four, five. So if you have a cruise line
company in your mix, you have an unusual
company.
It might get much of its revenues from
US or Europe, you know, tourists from
the US or Europe, but its tax rate is
close to 0%. So if you follow this
process, they shouldn't borrow money or
they should borrow very little. But
cruise cruise ship companies borrow
immense amounts of money because each
cruise ship is so expensive and they
don't want to issue equity. And then
they pay the debt down. And then they
repeat the process again. They pay the
debt down. It's almost like they know
they shouldn't be doing what they're
doing.
And then they try to remove it, but then
the process repeats again.
But from a financial perspective, if I
take away the tax benefits of debt, you
shouldn't borrow money.
Second thing that drives what your
optimal debt ratio is, remember this
process for computing optimal debt
ratios is built around whether you can
make those interest payments. Remember,
a big driver of your ratings is the
interest coverage ratio.
So if I hold all else constant, the more
earnings you make
relative to your market value, the
higher your optimal debt ratios. And the
keyword is relative to your market
value.
So one of the ways to look at what your
company can afford to pay out is look at
the EBITDA and that's a very rough proxy
for operating cash flow and divided by
the enterprise value, which is market
value of equity plus debt minus cash. So
it's a measure of the market value of
the company.
The higher that EBITDA to EV, the more
debt you can afford to borrow because in
effect, you have more cash available to
service debt payments.
In fact, a lot of private equity
investors use the inverse of that. EV to
EBITDA is one of the proxies for, "Hey,
should I go out and target a company?" A
low EV to EBITDA is a sign that you can
carry a lot of debt assuming you can
keep the EBITDA going.
What I've done is I have a computed the
EBITDA to enterprise value for my
companies. As you can see, Vale and Tata
Motors stand out. Their EBITDA is almost
17 and 1/2%
of their enterprise value. Their optimal
debt ratios get driven by the fact they
have a lot of cash flows.
The fact that they're in emerging
markets pushes against them, but they
still have a lot of cash flows. At the
other extreme, take a look at Baidu.
Incredibly successful company,
but success in the marketplace where you
your market value gets pushed up
actually makes your EBITDA a lower
percentage of enterprise value. If you
get a chance,
compute the EBITDA to enterprise value
for Nvidia.
Even after the markdown in the last
couple of weeks, the number is going to
be tiny because if your market cap is
two two and a half three trillion
dollars and much of it has been gained
on expectations for the future, what you
have is EBITDA right now can't service
that much EV.
So anybody who's picked Nvidia, don't be
surprised if you come up with a lower or
higher What are you going to get as an
as an as an optimal debt ratio?
You have low EBITDA relative to your
enterprise value. You're going to come
up with a low optimal debt ratio. You
say, "That doesn't make sense. Nvidia is
such a great company." It makes complete
sense. It's precisely because everybody
thinks it's a great company that your
optimal debt ratio is going to be low.
Remember that life cycle that that I
showed you early in the life cycle, your
EBIT is going to be a low percentage of
enterprise value because so much of your
value is coming from future growth. As
you mature, that EBIT is now going to
become a higher percentage of enterprise
value.
And you can afford to borrow more money.
So, tax rates matter, how much you
generate as cash flows matter.
Does your operating risk matter?
Absolutely. Where does it show up in the
optimal? Indirectly.
Why indirectly? Because I used EBIT from
the most recent year, right? To compute
how much I can borrow. But if I have a
company where the EBIT goes up and down,
it's volatile. I shouldn't be borrowing
based on last year's EBIT. I should be
looking at what I would generate as EBIT
in an average year. So, that's the first
place it shows up.
Second, remember the unlevered beta gets
magnified as you borrow money. If you
have a lot of operating risk, you will
tend to have a much higher unlevered
beta.
And third, remember the ratings agencies
don't just look at interest coverage
ratios, they look at how stable your
EBIT is to give you a rating. So, if you
have unstable earnings, you're probably
going to get a much lower rating.
Higher unlevered beta, lower rating, and
the fact that you've got to normalize
your operating income will all mean that
if you have a volatile company, a
company where earnings are you're going
to get a much much lower optimal debt
ratio than if you have stable earnings.
So, tax rate matters, cash flows matter,
how stable those cash flows are matter.
The only macro variable that seems to
drive optimal debt ratios
is the relative price of risk in the
equity market versus the bond market.
That sounds mysterious.
But did we have we talked about the
price of risk in the equity market? What
do we call it?
The equity risk premium, right? And I
showed you that graph of the implied
equity risk That's the red line over
time.
Is there a price of risk in the bond
market? Yes, it's called the default
spread. The second line, this brown
line, is the bond default spread for a
BAA rated bond. One So, basically in
both the equity market and the bond
market, the price of risk changes.
Most of the time, the two move together.
When you get scared in one market, you
get scared in the other. I started on
the process of computing equity risk
premium by day last week. Why? Not
because I wanted to, but because the
world is shifting and the price of risk
is changing. I'm also tracking the
default spread on the BAA rated bond.
Last week, what what do you think
happened to equity risk premium? We
talked about in the last session, the
equity risk premiums jumped and they've
continued to climb through Monday and
Tuesday and probably through today.
The bond default spreads across the
board have also shifted upwards. Last
week,
the default spread on a BAA rated bond
increased by almost 50 basis points.
That's a huge jump in the default
spread.
What's scaring the equity market is also
scaring the bond market. So, most of the
time, the two move together and you can
see it in this graph. But there have
been two periods in history,
at least in the la- in recent history,
where the two have moved in different
directions. The first was the late
1990s. Focus on what's happening to the
red line. What's happening to the equity
risk premium? It's collapsing. It's
getting lower and lower. That's the
dot-com boom.
It got as low as 2%. Remember in '99?
But during that period, default spreads
actually held pretty stable.
So, let's say you're a CFO of a company.
It's 1999.
The equity risk premium
is down to 2%. People are charging only
2% more than the risk-free rate to buy
your equity, which means they're paying
a high price for stocks.
But in the bond market, they're charging
a 2% default spread for an investment
grade bond.
So, the price of risk in the equity
market is low, the price of risk in the
bond market is high, at least on a
relative basis. 1999, if you're a
company raising capital, where are you
going to go? Equity or debt? Holding all
else constant.
Equity, they're charging you too low
a risk premium.
Debt, they're charging you too high.
You're going to go with equity because
it is going to give you a much higher
price. You're going to raise the equity.
And that's what companies did in 1999.
The problem fixed itself. And then 9/11
happened and Alan Greenspan said, "I'm
not going to let the US economy go into
recession." The hubris of central
bankers.
But it worked for a while.
For the next few years, if you look at
what happened, bond default spreads
collapsed. See the black line?
For a variety of reasons. So, you're
charging lower and lower spreads,
but the equity risk premium stays high.
So, now it's 2004, 2005, 2006. Bond
default spreads have become too low.
Equity risk premiums are high.
What are you going to do? You're going
to borrow till the cows come home and
actually buy back stock because you're
getting the the best of both sides.
Think of this as a golden time to do
leveraged buyouts, right? You're going
to borrow money.
That too blew up in 2008.
Eventually, these mismatches go away,
but they can cause distortions in what
companies do, either issue too much
equity or too much debt.
So, that's why I'm going to track both
the equity risk premium and the bond
default spread on a daily basis because
if there's divergence, that's
troublesome because that divergence can
give rise to distortions in how
companies finance.
So, as you look at your company, you
know, and you're welcome to use my
spreadsheet I've already sent to you,
but don't make it a black box. At least
take one or two debt ratios and see by
hand what's going on.
I will do what I did for Disney for your
company. So, you'll enter the numbers
for your company, so you'll have to do
that. The inputs have to come from you.
I'll do all No, zero to 90% debt ratios,
cost of capital at every debt ratio.
I'll even finish it up by saying, "If
you go to the optimal, this is how you
how much your value will increase by
using the approach I used for Disney."
This is not about you running the
spreadsheet. I'm doing the spreadsheet
for you. It's about you looking at the
output you get for your company saying,
"Why? Why is my company's optimal 20 or
30 or 40%?" And think of that as kind of
general advice on how to approach the
project. The project is not about
churning out what your cost of capital
is, what your optimal debt ratio is, you
know, how you know, what what the
dividends you could have paid are. It's
about explaining why your company has
the numbers that it is. Why does it have
a low cost of capital? Why is the
optimal debt ratio 20%?
Why isn't the company paying out what it
can afford to dividends? Make it more
about the why than the what because the
what is simple. I mean, I could you
know, you could probably turn ChatGPT
loose on your company with my
spreadsheets, it could come up with the
numbers. This is about you reading the
numbers.
So, any questions about the cost of
capital approach? Either the traditional
cost of capital where you just minimize
the cost of capital or the enhanced cost
of capital where you're trying to
maximize the value of the firm.
So, now I'm going to talk about a third
way of approaching the opt- So, let's
see where we are with Disney. With the
traditional cost of capital approach, my
optimal debt ratio was 40%.
With the enhanced cost of capital
approach where I brought in the effect
of ratings on operating income, it was
still 40%.
The third approach to coming up with an
optimal called the adjusted present
value approach or the APV approach.
It's an approach that was developed at
the University of Chicago in the 1970s.
It's become part of capital structure
law where people talk about using the
adjusted present value approach. What's
different about the adjusted present
value approach is instead of working
through the cost of capital, which is
what we've done,
here's what it does. It first values a
company as if it were all equity funded.
It's called an unlevered firm value.
So, we'll talk about the mechanics of
doing that. It's not difficult to do.
Then it brings in the effect of debt
through its two main ingredients, the
plus and minus. Biggest plus ingredient
for debt is a tax advantage it brings in
as a plus.
But then it subtracts out the expected
bankruptcy cost you've created for
yourself by borrowing that money. So, it
brings in the effect of debt through
that second ingredient. What does that
do to me? So, there's a a lure to this
approach because it keeps the financing
separate from the business. And from
that perspective, I like the approach.
But let's look at the practicality
of this approach. To use this approach,
you have to go through a three-step
process. First, you got to value your
company as if it has no debt.
And I'll give you two pathways to doing
it.
Remember when we did betas, we talked
about an unlevered beta? And the way we
described an unlevered beta is this is
the beta you would have as a company if
you had no debt.
Do I have an unlevered beta for Disney?
Yeah. That's where I started, 0.9239.
Can I estimate a cost of equity at that?
Yes, risk-free rate plus that beta times
risk premium. And if this company had no
debt, that would become the cost of
capital because all of your capital
would come from equity.
I would value Disney with that unlevered
cost of equity.
That becomes because value the company
is your cash flows before debt payments
discounted back at a cost of capital.
So, one way to do this is to actually
compute an unlevered firm value using
the unlevered cost of equity.
But that requires a full valuation. So,
I'll give you a shortcut
because in capital structure, you want
to be focused on capital structure. We
know the existing market value the firm,
right?
So, at Disney, I can look up the market
cap. Does that already incorporate the
effects of debt? Yes, it incorporates
the effect of the existing debt ratio in
the form of tax benefits in the debt and
expected bankruptcy cost. Let's say I
could reverse engineer and take out
those effects. Take the existing market
value, remove the tax benefits from
debt. So, that I'd have to quantify it.
So, I'm saying I'm no longer going to
have the tax benefits and add back the
expected bankruptcy cost because if I
take the debt, that bankruptcy cost I
can back out from the existing market
value the unlevered firm value. Sounds
abstract, but I'll do it for Disney so
you can see it play out. So, basically
two ways to get the unlevered firm value
and usually people get that one way or
the other.
So, that's the first step.
Second step is to estimate the tax
benefit of debt and this is the easiest
slice.
What's the tax benefit of debt?
It's the interest rate times the tax
rate, right? That's on an annual basis.
The present value of those
tax benefits over time is the tax
benefit of debt. In fact, in the very
special case where debt is assumed to be
a perpetuity, that this debt is
permanent, you can actually just take
the debt and multiply it by the tax
rate. The interest rate kind of
disappears because it's important in the
numerator and then as a disc
So, you tell me you borrow a billion
dollars, your tax rate is 25%. The tax
benefits of that debt are 250 million
dollars. A billion dollars times 25%.
So, that was easy. So, you got the
unlevered firm value.
You got the expected tax benefits and
then you enter enter what I call
nightmare territory.
To estimate an expected bankruptcy cost,
I need a probability of bankruptcy and I
think I can get that. That's that's not
as nightmarish.
But I have to multiply it by a
bankruptcy cost which includes both
direct and indirect cost.
And that's where the nightmare scenario
kicks in. What's the aspect of an
indirect bankruptcy cost?
Is you don't see it, right? The customer
who doesn't come into your showroom
is really a customer lost, but you don't
see who those customers are.
The employees who leave your company
because they're worried you might not
make it, you don't chronicle why why
they leave.
And you got to estimate it. So, here's
what happens in practice. So, when you
get on the desk and you're talking to
somebody says, "I use the APV approach."
Let them dig the hole that they're going
to bury themselves in. I say, "I've
never heard of it. Can you please
explain to me what it is?"
And they will to show you how much they
know.
They'll tell you, "We'll start with the
unlevered firm value and they'll go
through all kinds of mechanics. Probably
spend 30 minutes
on this is how I get free cash flow to
the firm. Do you know what a free cash
flow to the firm is?" Act like you
don't. Let them gain explain it. And
after they're done with the unlevered,
that's what's amazing. Then what do you
do next? They say, "I take the dollar
debt, multiply by the tax rate." Okay,
that's that's very creative. And capture
the tax benefit.
And then they will stop and say, "We're
done." And they say,
"What about the expected bankruptcy
cost?" And one response you'll get is,
"What expected bankruptcy cost?" In
practice, here's what the adjusted
present value approach becomes. It's the
unlevered firm value
plus the tax benefits of debt
and then you do a lot of hand waving and
so you're going to ignore the bankruptcy
cost. Let's play it out. If you count
all the good stuff that comes from debt
and none of the bad stuff in the APV
approach, what's your optimal debt ratio
going to end up becoming?
99.9% debt, right?
This is why LBO guys like the APV
approach because it justifies what they
do. Why do you go to a 90% debt ratio? I
use the APV approach. How convenient.
If you're going to do use the APV
approach, you have to try to bring the
expected bankruptcy cost
I don't use the APV approach much.
But if I did, here's what I would do to
get the expected bankruptcy cost. I need
two numbers. I need a probability of
bankruptcy. I need a cost of bankruptcy.
Here's how I'm going to estimate the
probability of bankruptcy. Remember in
the cost of capital approach, I
estimated a
synthetic rating at every debt ratio,
AAA, single A, triple B. You know the
advantage of having a rating is we have
100 years of corporate bond ratings and
the default rates on each ratings class.
Ed Altman
used to teach a bankruptcy the distress
and bankruptcy cost here. Used to update
it every I think Merrill Lynch does it
now and the ratings agencies themselves
have also picked up this practice. So,
you go to either Moody's or S&P, you can
see what percentage of bonds within each
ratings class defaulted in the 10 years
after the version.
So, with triple A, it's going to be a
tiny number, very very It's not zero.
It's 0.03%,
but as you go down the ratings classes,
the likelihood of default increases.
That's what I'm going to use to estimate
a probability of default is I'm going to
estimate a synthetic rating, go to that
table and say, "Your rating is triple B,
there's a 7 and 1/2% chance
of default. That's my probability of
bankruptcy."
The cost of bankruptcy, I'm going to do
the hand waving. Remember, this was not
my weapon of choice. You forced me in
here, but I'm not going to assume it's
zero, right? That's an assumption as
well.
The direct bankruptcy cost we have a
pretty good sense on. There was a study
of railroads that went bankrupt in the
1970s, which was pretty much every
single railroad. That's how Amtrak was
created.
And looked at what percentage of the
assets were used to cover the cost,
legal cost, bankruptcy cost, the fact
that you have to sell the assets. It's
about 10%, maybe 15%. That's the direct
cost.
But there's an indirect cost and that
indirect cost we said should vary across
companies. Remember, grocery stores
should have a lower indirect bankruptcy
cost than aircraft makers.
That cost can be anywhere from 5 to 25%
depending on where in the spectrum you
fall.
So, you're an aircraft maker, your total
bankruptcy cost are going to be 10% plus
an extra 30% for that indirect
bankruptcy cost. If you're a grocery
store, be 10% plus 5%. You're saying
that's a lot of hand waving. I agree.
That's why I use the cost of capital
approach, but you push me into the APV
approach, I'm going to give it my best
shot.
So, let's try this.
Now, this is the table actually that
that that Ed Altman had updated at the
time that I did that Disney APV I'll
give you the updated version of this
table. It's on my It's on my web website
somewhere. So, basically you can see if
you're a triple A rated, the probability
of default is 0.07%. This is over the
next 10 years.
D-rated, it's you're done. You're
already in default, but you can see zero
to 100% depending on your synthetic
rating.
So, I'm going to try this on Disney.
I'm going to use that approach of
starting with the market value. There's
the market value, current enterprise
value for Disney, 137.839
billion.
That's what the market is valuing the
company. Let's take that as as the fair
value because that's going to be for
whether it's under or overvalued is a
different question. Here I want to focus
on the capital structure. Do they have
debt? Yes, they have 15.961 billion in
debt and the marginal tax rate was
36.1%. I'm going to use the shortcut.
That is what the tax benefit is from
debt. And if I don't have debt, that tax
benefit will disappear. So, I subtract
it out.
I want to make sure that you're that you
get why I'm subtracting it out. The
question I'm asking is, "Disney
currently has debt at its market value.
What will happen to its value if the
company pays off all its debt?" If it
does, the tax benefits disappear. So, I
take out the tax benefits. But if I
take out the tax benefits from debt, I
pay off the debt, I also take out the
bankruptcy risk that's embedded with
that debt. So, I add back that expected
bankruptcy cost which is small because
it's single A rated company, 0.66% was
the chance of failure.
And I did make an assumption that the
bankruptcy cost for Disney would fall
somewhere between the grocery store, 5%
and the aircraft maker, 45%. I picked
25% as my expected
the bankruptcy cost if that I'm going to
build into my expected value. So, 0.66%
times
the 25% of 137.839 is 227 billion. I'm
adding it back because if I pay off the
debt, that bankruptcy risk goes away.
The value that I get of 132.3 billion is
my unlevered value. It's the value that
Disney would have if they paid off all
their debt, retired all their debt
because the tax benefits would go away,
the bankruptcy risk goes away. That's
going to become my starting point.
I'm going to use that and ask at every
debt ratio, what will that debt ratio do
in terms of bringing in added tax
benefits and affecting my expected
bankruptcy cost. So, in this table, the
132.304
remains the same. That's the unlevered
firm value. That doesn't change. But as
my debt goes from 13 to 27 to 41 to 55
billion, I compute the tax benefits as
that debt times the tax rate.
Only qualifier I'll add is my tax rate
once I get past 7 60% drops off. And
remember why that happens is because my
interest expense So, I'm actually using
my cost of capital table to generate my
APV table as well.
Is because once I get past that now that
maximum debt, my tax benefits kind of
level off.
In fact, they start to go down because I
bring in a bankruptcy risk in there and
I might not get the tax benefit that
happens. To compute my bankruptcy risk,
I first compute the synthetic rating
which comes out of my cost of capital
analysis and estimate a probability of
default. And as you can see, the chance
of Disney defaulting goes from 0.07%
when they have no debt to 85% when they
have 90% debt.
Okay, no surprises. That probability of
bankruptcy multiplied by that 25% of
value gives me an expected bankruptcy
cost and that number starts to mount as
I get to higher and higher debt ratios.
Ultimately, the value that I get for the
firm is the unlevered value plus the tax
benefit minus the expected bankruptcy
cost and as you can see that number
starts to climb initially. The tax
benefits overwhelm the bankruptcy cost.
But it levels off.
And it's very convenient that it levels
off at what debt ratio?
It looks like it's at 40%.
Will this always happen? Almost never. I
just got lucky here or maybe tweak with
the numbers to make it look like they
converge.
No.
The approaches make different slightly
different perspectives and I'm drawing
on the same raw data.
But basically here I'm looking at debt
as an add-on to an unlevered firm value
to come up with the expected value.
So, can we do a PV right? Yes, but it's
I in my view a lot more work
and a lot more hand-waving than the cost
of capital approach.
So, when people complain about the cost
of capital approach and say they'll do
the APV approach, as I said, let them
dig their own hole till you get to the
expected bankruptcy cost.
And if they don't bring it in, this is a
half-assed APV. Maybe we should have
this third category of APV half-assed
APV and you know, it really is not going
to give you an optimal because you're
counting on only the good stuff.
Any questions on the adjusted present
value approach?
So, basic difference is in the
traditional cost of capital approach,
the benefits and the cost of debt are
captured in the cost of capital. Here
they're captured with that extra
component of tax benefit and expected
bankruptcy cost.
So, as
as you look across the three approaches,
even if you don't have a finance
background,
this isn't rocket science, right? All
we're doing is changing the mix, a few
mechanical details along the way.
And if you're a hundred-billion-dollar
firm, a trillion-dollar market cap firm,
you'd assume that somebody in the
company must be doing something like
this
to decide how much to borrow.
I don't think so.
If you ask me how most companies decide
how much to borrow, it's by looking at
their peer group and they have to define
what their peer group is and looking at
what they do and trying to stay as close
as you can
to what they do.
And we've kept we've talked about
me-tooism all through this class.
Capital structure, you see that
me-tooism kicking. What's the advantage
if you're a company of being close to
the peer group
when you decide how much to borrow?
What's the advantage of doing what
everybody else is doing?
Be a six-year-old, right?
You know the classic six-year-old
mother-conversation. Fathers usually
don't enter this conversation.
The six-year-old does something really
stupid at school.
He or she comes home and says, you know,
is confronted, why did you that stupid
thing? And you know what the classic
six-year-old response is, right? Which
is
everybody else was doing it, too.
To which the classic mother response is,
if everybody else jumped off a bridge,
would you jump off the bridge, too? And
if you're a normal six-year-old, the
answer is, of course I would.
I don't want to look strange.
So, wait, what's the advantage of being
close to the peer group?
Or when you screw up,
your defense is, don't blame me, we were
all doing it.
Telecom companies late '90s got
incredibly over-levered.
It's No, and then the trouble start.
People say, why did you borrow so much
money? And the response was, everybody
else was doing it. Korean companies
collectively borrowed too much money in
the 1990s. Their defense was, everybody
else was doing it.
Don't underestimate that because it
would mean that you can survive even the
worst, most horrendous decisions because
everybody else was doing it.
So, I understand this urge to be close
to peer group and ignoring it doesn't
make it go away, but at least have some
good sense recognize that even if you
have a peer group, there are differences
across the peer group and they should
play out in how much you borrow.
So, if you're Ryanair, what's your peer
group going to be?
Probably other European airlines, right?
But I would expect Ryanair to borrow
less money than that peer group. So,
even if you're comparing it to the
industry average, why? Because they have
a lower tax rate. So, even though you're
a peer group, at least bring in those
considerations.
If you're a company you're
if you're a company with a, you know,
across a group where you have less
inside ownership than other companies, I
would expect you to borrow more money
because of the agency issues. We talked
about, you know, the added discipline
argument. Go through argument by
argument for what drives the optimal
debt ratio and at least control for
that. If you're more risky than the
typical company in your peer group, you
should borrow less because you're more
bankruptcy risk.
So, everything that plays in the optimal
will also play out in your peer group.
So, let's try out peer group analysis
with this added dimension of I want to
control for differences.
So, I took four of my companies. Notice
again, I'm keeping Deutsche out of the
mix because if you ask me what the debt
ratio for a peer group is, I can't give
it to you, but I can compare to you one
capital ratios across banks and we do
that all the time.
So, there are my four companies. I've
computed the debt ratio and I've allowed
for multiple variants of it. Why?
Because if you're doing peer group
borrowing,
there's no reason why you have to use
market value debt to capital. You might
be comparing across book values, you
might be doing net debt ratios rather
than gross debt ratios. So, basically
I've computed variants. Yeah. And you
can see for Disney, the book value debt
ratio is 23%. The market debt ratio is
12%. Net debt ratio's book value is 18%,
market value is 9%.
I define the peer group as US
entertainment companies. My guess is
that's what Disney probably compares
itself more to.
And if you look at the book value,
market value book, you know,
I might just be cynical here, but it
looks at least like looking at those
numbers that Disney is trying to stay
pretty close to an industry average.
Okay. You go to Vale.
Pretty high debt ratio. Remember that
looked over-levered looking at the
optimal? But you look at the rest of the
business, again you see the same
phenomenon kick out. You're comparing
it. So, with every one of these
companies, you look at their actual debt
ratios. You look at the peer group, you
can see the drive of the peer group.
A couple of, you know, Baidu has a low
debt ratio, but it's in a sector where
everybody borrows very little money.
Most companies look at their debt ratios
don't want to be outliers. They don't
want as Wade said, an analyst asking,
why do you have so much? Because let's
face it, laziness breeds laziness,
right? If the only way an analyst decide
whether you have too much debt is by
comparing your debt ratio to your peer
group, then what are you going to try to
do? You're going to try to play on those
same dimensions.
So, if you're advising a company on an
optimal debt ratio, even if you use the
cost of capital approach,
you should at least be aware of what the
peer group looks like because I can
almost guarantee you after your
presentation, the CFO is going to ask,
if we do this, will we look strange?
And you got to be ready for that
question.
But if you want to keep within the peer
group and control for differences in
taxes and risk, there's a way to do it
now that you might not have been able to
use 40 years ago.
I mean, take the, you know, take the
entertainment company or the automobile
business. Lots of companies in the
group, but they're very diverse, right?
Some are small, some are large, some are
risky, some are safe, some have high tax
rates, some have low tax rates.
But Tata Motors, for instance, the
global automobile business is a very
diverse business. And when you have lots
of different variables that you think
might be affecting the choices companies
make, you can open up your statistics
books. What are you trying to explain?
Differences in debt ratios across
companies.
What are you going to use? You're going
to look at the tax rate, how volatile
earnings are, and how much cash flow the
company has. So, let's I just threw in
those three. It doesn't have to be just
those three.
What am I doing when I run the
regression? I'm looking to see whether
the differences in debt ratios across
companies can be explained by
differences in tax rates, differences in
variability of earnings,
and differences in cash flows.
Could none of those work? Absolutely.
The data is the data. If I find no
differences, I'm going to say, you know
what? Just compare yourself to the
average. In this sector, nobody seems to
care about any of those things. But if I
do see differences across companies, I
now have a basis for estimating what you
should borrow given what the peer group
is doing, but also controlling for
differences in risk, cash flows, and tax
rates.
I know it sounds abstract, but that's
exactly what I did with the automobile
business in 2013.
I took every 56 global automobile
company companies, took their debt to
capital, it's the market debt to
capital, ran a regression against the
tax rate, EBITDA as a percent of
enterprise value, that captures your
cash flows, and how much these companies
had as capex because we have a lot of
capex, you are much more dependent upon
external financing.
So, first look at the coefficients. The
higher my tax rate, the higher the debt
to cap ratio, which makes sense. High
tax rates, you should borrow more. The
higher my cash flows, the higher my debt
to cap ratio. More cash flows, again.
And the more capex I have, the more
concerned I seem to be about borrowing
money. It actually lowers my optimal
debt ratio.
So, you put those numbers in and the R
squared of the regression is 21%.
Now, if you're in a statistics class,
you try to push through a regression
with an R squared of 21%.
You're going to be in trouble, right?
Why does 79% you're not able to explain
with these three variables?
Luckily, you're not in a statistics
class.
This is what the data tells you. And
again, this is not how I wanted to come
up with an op- debt debt ratio for you.
You chose to compare yourself to a peer
group. And what I'm saying is within
your peer group, I can't explain what's
going on. This is a very dangerous game
you're playing, but if you choose to
play it, I can give you a debt ratio.
The 21% R squared means the range around
that prediction is going to be wide.
But this is your choice. You want to
compare to the peer group, this is what
you get. In fact, I plugged the numbers
in for Tata Motors, their tax rate,
EBITDA, and CAPEX. I came up with an
18.5%
optimal debt to gap ratio.
What does that tell me?
If I use the peer group, control for
differences to predict the debt ratio
for Tata Motors,
they should have 18.5% debt. They were
actually at about 29%
actual debt ratio. Incidentally, with
the cost of capital approach, the
optimal debt ratio I came up with Tata
Motors was 20%. It's actually pretty
close to peer group analysis here.
But again, that happens to be the case
with this company, that might not be the
case with every company.
So, you can take your company, look at
your peer group.
And that's the advantage now of of
databases like Capital IQ. You can
download the data for every automobile
company, debt, capital, debt to capital,
and then compute in a tax rate, whatever
you think will drive that number. And
then see, are there differences I can
explain and can I use those to make a
better peer group-based assessment of my
company.
Now, why am I staying with the
automobile companies? Because there
might be differences across sectors. On
what dimensions? On risk and cash flows.
But if a regression can control for
those differences, could I run this
regression across the entire market?
I don't see why not.
Start of every year. In fact, I do this
for US companies
and for global companies. I take the
debt ratio, and this was 2014. You can
find the 2025 version on my webpage.
I'll send you the link to it.
What I do is I take every publicly
traded company. So, let's say with the
US sample,
for every US company,
I take the The variables I throw in are
variables that I think should matter
based on that original trade-off and
debt. The tax rate isn't there because
of the tax benefits of debt. The percent
of shares held by institutions is a
rough measure of that discipline issue
that I have to worry about. Maybe
that'll that'll measure it.
The variance in earnings captures how
much I worry about bankruptcy risk. And
the cash flow I capture with this EBITDA
divided by enterprise value. So,
in the in when when I ran this for the
for the US firms in 2014, there were
2,000 companies in my sample. That's a
plus. I have a really big sample.
The minus is all kinds of companies in
this mix, right? And some of them might
be doing completely crazy things. Where
does that show up?
My R squared is 8%. Am I concerned about
it? What's concerned going to do to it?
It's not going to raise it. It's not
going to lower it. It basically is
telling me across the market, there are
huge variations in debt ratios you
cannot explain based on the
fundamentals.
It is what it is.
That's why I choose not to compare to a
peer group. But since you chose to do
this,
this is what your debt ratio should look
like.
So, I don't know what this year's R
squared was, but it wasn't great. It's
like 12%.
I keep track of that number, but really
to give you a sense of how much
uncertainty there is when you base your
debt ratios on what everybody else is
doing.
People are driven by all kinds of
decisions on this.
So, I took Disney's numbers in 2014,
plugged it into the market regression.
So, I These are the numbers for Disney.
Plugged into the market regression, I
get a predicted debt ratio for Disney of
19%.
Given how the rest of the market or the
rest of the companies in the market are
setting debt ratios,
and given Disney's specific
characteristics, it should borrow about
19% of its capital from debt.
Well below my optimal from the cost of
capital approach, right?
But it reflects that's what companies in
the market are doing, that's what you
should try to do.
So, you can see why this can be
different.
If everybody in the market is is trying
to get to an optimal debt ratio like the
cost of capital, the predicted value
here should be pretty close to what you
get with the optimal debt ratio.
Remember we talked about Korea where in
the mid-90s because governments stepped
in and protected companies from
bankruptcy, that every Korean company
borrowed too much money. When I use a
market regression, then it's going to
tell you, "You look okay."
Given what everybody else is doing.
That's a very dangerous qualifier, cuz
if everybody else is behaving in a crazy
way, you're just like everybody else.
You're crazy,
but relative everybody else, you look
pretty sane.
That's what peer group assessment does
is it basically locks you into what
everybody else is doing. I'll tell you
when I worry the most about peer. When
the entire peer group is going through
disruption.
The underlying characteristics of the
business are changing.
This kind of way of borrowing can get
you into trouble. The reason telecom
companies ended up over-levered was not
that they were borrowing more than they
did in the 1980s. It's a business itself
went from being regulated monopolies
to technology company type of risk. The
business was changing, but everybody to
borrow as if it was 1983.
The time you get to '97, '98, '99, you
were borrowing against a much riskier
business.
The fact that everybody was borrowing
too much didn't protect you from the
downside of having borrowed too much.
But it's always good to be aware of what
the rest of the market is doing, rest of
the sector. Doesn't mean you should do
the same thing.
So,
for each of my companies, I tried all of
the approaches. Maybe a little bit of
overkill, right? Cuz I did the cost of
capital and So, if you take Disney,
their actual debt ratio was about 12%.
And I did standard operating So, the
operating income approach, I just let
the operating income vary to see when
how much can I borrow. Wouldn't even go
through that approach. But the cost of
capital, the enhanced cost of capital,
APV, all gave me 40%. When I compared to
the entertainment business and ran a
regression across entertainment
companies, I got about 28.5%
and you saw the market-based prediction,
19%. 19 through 40. What do they all
share in common?
They're all higher than my 12%. On every
single approach, Disney looks like it
has too much debt.
I'm willing to accept that the right
optimal the right debt ratio might be
20, 25, 30, but
could Disney afford to borrow more money
in 2014? Absolutely.
Have they chosen not to? Yes. Does that
make them irrational? Not necessarily.
That's going to be the next thing is why
do companies choose not to be at the
optimal?
But it looks under-levered on every
dimension. Let's take Vale. 35.48%.
It's their actual. The optimal that I
got with the actual operating income is
30%. Remember we talked about
normalizing the earnings? If you use the
earnings across the cycle,
they get at 50%. Their enhanced cost of
capital, 30 to 40. The bottom line is
you look across those debt ratios,
what's your conclusion going to be for
Vale?
Roughly, I mean, it's I'm not going to
go crazy. It's not over-levered. It
might be slight It's pretty close to
where it should be given its optimal.
If you look at Tata Motors, op- The
actual debt ratio is 29%. Every single
try that I got gave me a number lower. I
feel pretty comfortable saying, "Hey,
you know what? Tata Motors has too much
debt." Not so much that it's going to go
bankrupt, but it's clearly carrying more
debt using every single approach. And
finally, with Baidu, 5.23%.
You know, you can see that the the with
the APV approach, you got 20%, but every
other approach, you get around 10%.
Remember, because we go in 10%
increments, when I say the optimal debt
ratio is 10%, I'm really saying it's
around 10%. Could be six, it could be
14.
So, don't get too carried away. If you
get your company at a 24% actual debt
ratio and your optimal is 20%, don't
write a three-page treatise on how
over-levered it is. It is within
shouting distance. What you're looking
for are big differences between actual
and optimal, cuz then you can ask, "Why
is that happening with my company? What
is the company doing?"
So, let's review. You have a company,
you know what the numbers look like last
year.
You know,
if you're doing this at any company
right now,
say your optimal debt ratio says 30%.
Why might you hold back today?
Given where we are.
Who knows what the next year will bring,
right? We're at a point where historical
data on how higher income is and how
what You know, Disney you know, Apple
has lost like 20%
of its market cap just in the last few
weeks.
Why?
Cuz Apple's business model is built
around the smartphone. The smartphone
for the most part is made in Asia.
And sold in around the world.
And if the basis for that is changing,
that's going to change your operating
model. You either have to pass it
through to your customers who are
already
kind of unwilling. I mean, what what did
the iPhone 16 go for? $1,200? Something
like that?
I mean, the question is at $2,000, would
you upgrade your iPhone? Most people,
even people who used to upgrade might
say not necessarily. There's your
business model kind of pulling apart at
the seams.
So, when you look at these approaches,
you are building on history, but you
would also have to look at the macro
moment you're in.
And say, maybe I'll hold back.
And as I said, I was in Argentina last
week. Now, if you're an Argentine
company, how much should you borrow? As
little as possible, right?
Cuz you could be the most stable
Argentine company, but that's a relative
statement.
The entire macro environment can shift
overnight.
So, it's so be you know, be aware of the
mechanics, but also have some common
sense and taking those mechanics and
say, should we actually go to that
optimal debt ratio?
Any questions about optimal debt ratios?
As you go out there, I'm sure you will
run into people who said, "Do you
remember the Miller-Modigliani when you
talk about optimal debt ratios?" They'll
counter that. But Miller-Modigliani told
us that doesn't matter how much you
borrow. The answer to that should be?
Only in a world with
no taxes and no default risk.
That's not the world we live in.
Or you get this pushback of debt always
pushes down the cost of capital.
I heard Carl Icahn make this this
statement in 2012. He said Apple should
go out and borrow $300 billion
cuz debt costs only 3% and equity costs
more.
What was he missing? You borrow $300
billion, your cost of debt will not be
the 3% you used to borrow, it'll be much
higher. Borrowing money doesn't
necessarily lower your cost of capital.
Why? Because it pushes up both the cost
of equity and the cost of debt.
So, there are these illusory illusory
reasons, you know,
frictions that might drive you to say,
"Look, we're going to borrow money."
But step back and think about the
biggest benefit, tax benefit, the
biggest cost of bankruptcy cost. That
trade-off is what's going to determine
whether debt is good for you or not.
So, let's talk about
what to do after you've got the optimal
debt ratio.
So, I'm going to jump ahead I know how
many weeks I'll have to do this on your
project. You've done your optimal debt
ratio for your company. It has to get
done before May 5th. Let me put it that
way.
So, maybe it's May 3rd that you do it at
around midnight, maybe even May 4th, or
maybe just before class
10:15 on May 5th. But that's a drop dead
time.
You come up with an optimal debt ratio
for your company.
And you got an actual debt ratio. The
question is, what do we do next?
Because you're not on autopilot. ChatGPT
would say, "Just go to the optimal."
You're not ChatGPT. You're going to say,
"Look, I have an optimal debt ratio, an
actual debt ratio, but I have to live in
the world I'm in knowing everything I
know, what are the things I'm going to
factor in whether to go to the optimal?"
And if you choose to go to the optimal,
I have a follow-up question.
You want me to increase my debt ratio
from 12% to 40%.
What type of debt should I use?
Fixed rate or floating rate? So, that's
the second part is so, what kind of So,
let's start with the first of those
questions, right?
So, let's say you computed the optimal
debt ratio for your company, got the
actual debt ratio. One of three things
is going to be true.
Your company is roughly at its right
mix. In which case, what should you do?
Follow the Hippocratic oath. Do no harm.
Don't feel the urge to ask a company to
do something just because it feels like
you're
being more active. I mean, that's the
problem with being a consultant, right?
What if you're going to a company and
the company's already perfectly managed
and perfectly run?
You can tell them you're already
perfectly managed and perfectly run,
but you're a consultant. You got to tell
them there's something wrong.
So, you got to invent things that are
wrong so you can fix them, and that's
never a good path. So, if your company's
already at the right mix,
say, "Thank god, this part of the
project for me is easy.
Move on."
Right?
Your company could be underlevered. It
has too little debt.
Or it could be overlevered.
You can have a problem. Which one would
you rather have? Having too little debt
or too much debt?
Too little is always better. We'll talk
about the consequence of borrowing too
much. So, if you're going to make a
mistake, you'd rather Already you can
see then that when you compute the
optimal debt ratios of companies are
sensible,
more companies are going to be
underlevered than overlevered if you
have any kind of health in the economy.
So, the next step in this process, if
you have either underlevered or
overlevered, is whether to move to that
optimal.
You're saying, "Shouldn't you always
move to the optimal your cost of
capital?" Not necessarily.
You might choose to hold back. We'll
talk about some of the reasons
even if you have excess debt capacity
might choose to hold back. And if you
decide to move to the optimal, whether
you need to do it instantaneously
or over time.
Again, let's step back, think common
sense. Let's say your debt ratio is 10%,
your optimal is 40%.
Moving instantaneously means going out
and doing something big. Now, borrowing
$20 billion and buying back stock.
Moving gradually gives you more options,
right? You could pay dividends, you
could take projects.
So, that's the second choice. And third,
to make that change, what exactly you're
going to do? Because there are two ways
you can change your debt ratio. One is
to recapitalize.
Borrowing money, paying a dividend,
borrowing money and buying back stock.
The other is
to actually take projects, borrow money
and take investments. You're saying,
"Which So, already you can see for each
company those pathways are going to be
different, whether you know, how quickly
you move and the process by which you
move."
So, I'm going to give you a framework
that I find useful. This is, you know,
framework that you can see from the font
it's like 25 years old. I haven't really
messed with it.
So, this is after you've done your
optimal debt ratio, right? So, let's say
actual debt ratio greater or less than
the optimal.
I've There's a third path that I've
ignored. If you're already the optimal,
the
the entire framework stops at the first
step, you can do nothing. But let's say
you're underlevered.
So, you have an actual debt ratio of
10%, optimal of 40%.
The first question you ask is, "Do I
need to do something right away?"
To answer the question, you have to ask,
"What is the consequence of being
underlevered?" Something that can happen
soon that I've got to put off.
And I'm going to argue that if you're
underlevered, one of the threats you
might face
is that somebody might
take you over. You're saying, "Why would
being underlevered make me a potential
threat for a takeover?"
It's because you made the acquirer's job
a lot easier, right? Because they can
borrow money on your assets
effectively to take you over.
Let me give you an analogy. Analogy is
not going to go all the way through, but
it's still worth thinking about.
Let's assume
you own a house
in the New York area. Even with housing
prices leveling off, it's going to
probably cost you what, $2 million, $3
million?
And let's say you I mean, to
to buy that house, you probably had to
borrow money unless you're a drug
dealer, right?
Or a banker with a really big bonus. So,
let's say you borrowed money to buy the
house and you're really frugal person.
You save every penny. It's got to be
more than pennies, every dollar, every
$100.
You don't use DoorDash. You eat eggs
every No, eggs are too expensive. You
eat something cheaper every day. No,
tuna out of a can.
And you pay off your debt.
You got the only all equity financed
house
in your neighborhood. Congratulations.
You decide to have a mortgage burning
party.
In the old days, when people actually
had houses that did 30-year mortgages
in, when the final mortgage payment was
made,
they would actually burn the mortgage
papers. They would invite the neighbors
with coffee cake and orange juice and
once in a while they'd burn the house
down with it. You know, which is kind of
ironic, you know, you own the house, but
there's nothing left. So, let's say you
decide to have a mortgage burning party,
but you also invite the local firemen in
just in case.
And you're sitting around your kitchen
table, and your neighbor Joe's never
liked you. He doesn't like the shrubs
you pick, he doesn't like the way you
cut your lawn. He just doesn't like you.
But he comes to the party anyway, it's
free food.
And while he's eating your coffee cake
and drinking your orange juice,
he's plotting his revenge.
So, right after the party, here's what
he does. And here's where the analogy
will kind of break down, but hang in
there anyway.
He goes to the friendly neighborhood
bank. It's a small town, everybody knows
everybody else.
And he decides
he goes to the banker and he says, "I'd
like to borrow
$1.8 million on my neighbor's house."
Here's where the the analogy gets a
little shaky. You go into a bank and you
try to borrow money on your neighbor's
house.
What's the response you're usually going
to get?
It's not your house. But this is your
friendly neighborhood banker. He lends
money against
He lets you borrow the money against
your neighbor's house. So, Joe now has
debt that he's borrowed using your house
as backing, and he does a hostile
acquisition
of your house. Here again, I don't know
how the analogy work. You'd probably
have to have kids own a slice of the
house,
and they sell you out.
For a premium. So, he approaches your
kids and say, "Sell me your share."
And he acquires 51% of your house.
And then he throws you out of your
house. Thank God this analogy doesn't
work.
But let's see how this would play out in
a business setting.
You're the CEO of a publicly traded
company with a market cap of a billion.
You've chosen not to borrow money. Why?
Because you don't like that. You're the
CEO. You don't like to borrow money.
I see your house.
Right?
And I said, "Look, that That I'm sorry.
I see your business." And I said, "That
business could have 600 million in debt.
Look, it's got lots of cash." I do a
cost of capital optimal debt ratio to
60%.
Then I go to the friendly neighborhood
banker, and I try the trick again. So,
there's this business with a
billion-dollar value. I'd like to borrow
600 million against business. The banker
probably going to say, "Is it your
business?" And you say, "Not really and
not yet."
He said, "I can't lend you money."
The game would have ended in 1979 or
1980 or 1981 on that.
You wouldn't have been able to do it.
And then
along came Mike Milken and Drexel
Burnham.
What did they do?
They allowed you to issue bonds to
market which were below investment
grade. You say, "How does it help me?"
I don't have to go to a bank, right? I
issue bonds.
And I said, "Look, I'm going to use the
cash from the this bond issue to buy
this company. I don't own the company
yet. Of course, it's risky." So, you pay
a high interest rate on the bond. Accept
a double B or a single B rating. I raise
600 million
in debt from the bond issue.
And then I acquire your company with
that. And if you're a conservative CEO,
in addition to not borrowing money, what
have you usually accumulated for me
conveniently in your company?
What do conservative managers do?
They accumulate cash.
Can't get any easier for me, right? I
borrow I buy your company using your
company as collateral to borrow money.
And after I borrow the money, I pay off
the debt with your cash.
Of course, I'm going to try to acquire
your company.
The late '80s, you had a bunch of
hostile acquisition leverage
acquisitions. The one thing they all
shared in common
was that they were all, you know, mature
companies could afford to have a lot of
debt, became these targets.
So, if your company's under levered,
that's the first question you ask. Am I
under threat of a hostile takeover?
Because if you are, you don't have time
on your as your ally. You got to do
something quickly.
You got to increase your debt ratio
quickly. How do you increase your debt
ratio quickly?
Well, you can't take debt and take
projects. That takes forever.
You go out and borrow money, and you got
to reduce equity. And what are the two
ways you can reduce equity?
You can either pay a special dividend or
you can buy back stock.
Effectively, what we did for Disney, you
can change it. So, if you're under
threat of a hostile acquisition, don't
sit there plotting 5-year or 10-year
plans. You got to do something quickly.
You can even try for a what's called a
debt for equity swap. What does that
mean? You go to equity invest in your
company and offer them debt of
equivalent value. Why would they take
it? Because they weren't planning to
sell your stock anyway and buy bonds.
Effectively, you're trying to change the
debt ratio quick.
So, let's say you play this out for your
company, right?
Wait, what Who are you doing?
Adidas. So, let's say that Adidas
optimal debt ratio is 40% and their
actual debt ratio is 20%. Is Adidas
under threat of a hostile
takeover?
Okay. Let's go through something. First,
you're going to look at the size of the
company, right?
Microsoft is under levered.
Is it under threat of a hostile
takeover?
I don't think so.
Why? First, you got to come up with $3
trillion, right? That's kind of tough to
do. The second problem is it's a company
which still has significant insider
holdings, and the insiders in the
company are probably not going to sell
to you. Bill Gates still owns a slice,
not as big a slice as he used to.
And third, is it a company that's done
pretty well in the market in the last
few years?
It's one of the mag seven. It's carried
the market. You got a trifecta working
against you. But Adidas current current
market market cap, how much is it? 100
and
40 billion, which is not Microsoft
levels. It's 40 billion today's market.
I mean, how much cash does Apple have?
200 billion. Maybe they need to leave
the smartphone business and buy Adidas
with petty cash.
They won't even notice, right? 40
billion, where did that go? It's okay,
you got Adidas in return. So, it's big,
but not so big that that alone would be
daunting. So, that's perhaps a a third
of a strike. In baseball, you can call
it strike or not. Let's call it a third
of a strike. It's It's big, but it's not
huge. What else might go into this mix?
Which works for the the acquirer, right?
Where is it incorporated?
Germany. Would that come into play?
Is it easier to acquire do a hostile
acquisition of a company in the US? And
Absolutely. Germany has all kinds of
rules on, you know, that you can put up
all kinds of barriers. It used to be
that if it was German company, I said,
"Game over right now. There will be no
hostile acquisition." Because there was
a time in mainland Europe where hostile
acquisitions were just not allowed.
They were just not done. You know why?
Because the people who would fund you
would not find you.
So, if you thought Fiat Chrysler was
badly run in 1985, and you went to an
Italian bank, and you're kind of stuck
with domestic banks, and say, "I'd like
to buy Fiat Chrysler in a hostile
acquisition."
The banker would not just have not lent
you money. He'd probably have had you
arrested and taken to the local police
station. You know, keep this person in
jail for a few years until these bad
thoughts pass.
But Germany is so That's clearly going
to make my life more difficult. How is
it stock price Did you do the Jensen's
alpha yet for your company?
Okay. So, let's say you do it,
and you come up with a number.
Let's say that number is positive. So,
what does the Jensen's alpha tell you?
That this stock has done better than
expected. I would say if you take the
sum of those things, pretty large
company, 40 billion. The fact that it's
in Germany, the fact that its stock
holders are right now not beating down
the doors. You can say, "You know what?
With Adidas, I have time on my side."
You can see that this is a subjective
judgment. But it's a judgment that's
going These things are going to feed How
big a user company?
Who owns the company? How much do
insiders own of the company? A lot of
insiders own the company, much more
difficult unless you can get one of them
on your side. Right?
And third, look at your Jensen's alpha.
That's why the project works
sequentially. It's good to do this after
you've done that regression beta page
and come up with the Jensen's alpha,
because that Jensen's alpha is going to
come into play. Say, "Do I trust this
company?"
And if your firm is a takeover
target, as I said, you got to do
something quickly. With Adidas, you have
the luxury of time.
You have the luxury of time.
You can get from 20 to 40%. You're going
to do it over 5 or 10 years. I'm going
to come back with a second question.
Does your company have good projects?
This is something we've done in this
class that that kind of gave us an
answer to whether Disney had good
projects. What did we compare?
Remember that tangent we took from the
return on capital? We compared the
return on capital for Disney as a
company to the cost of capital.
It's 12.81% return on capital. Cost of
capital 7.8%. So, basically, they were
earning about 4% more than the cost of
capital. We gave all
Maybe closer to 5%. I know it's a
accounting number, but it looks like
they have good projects.
If you have excess debt capacity, you
have time on your side, and you have
good projects,
it's always better to use the debt to
take good projects rather than to
recapitalize.
Leon, why is that? What's When you take
up good project, how does that affect
your value? First, what's the definition
of a good project in capital budgeting?
Or your NPV is positive. And when you
take a positive NPV project, it
increases your values, right? So, if you
take excess debt capacity, you take good
projects, you get a double whammy.
The first whammy is when you move to the
optimal, your cost of capital goes down,
your value goes up. And if you take good
projects, you get the NPV on those
projects on top of it. So, you have
great projects, and you have time on
your side, and you have debt capacity.
By all means, borrow money and take
projects.
But when I compare the return on capital
to the cost of capital, which again is
part five of the project, you know,
halfway through the class, and I came up
with the return capital less than the
cost of capital, I don't want you to go
out and take good those projects because
they will destroy value.
There, I'm going to say you got to
increase your debt ratio over time, and
you have two levers that you can
control. One is how much you pay in
dividends. Remember, each time you pay
dividends, your equity goes down.
Or you can buy back stock gradually over
time. The advantage of buying back stock
gradually over time is you can pick your
timing. Right? You'd much rather be
buying back stock today than 2 weeks
ago.
Cuz your stock price is down 20%.
It's nice to have that luxury. I have
debt capacity. I have cash. I'm going to
use it to buy back stock on my terms.
So, that's the
under-levered side and you can see it
play out. About and now I haven't looked
at your numbers, you haven't done your
numbers, I can't even look at them, but
eventually when those numbers come in on
May 5th, I'll make a prediction because
it's always been true. About 80% of your
companies are going to be under-levered.
And most of them will have time
on their side.
About a third of them will have great
projects.
And about two-thirds of them, you got a
devices plan of how to But, you're going
to see this play out with the
under-levered companies.
I'm going to hold off on the
over-levered because as I said, it's a
very unpleasant place to be. So, next
session when we start, we're going to
talk about what happens when you have
too much debt. How do you get out of the
problem? And you can see getting out of
an over-levered problem, all of your
standard ways of doing it. You're
saying, "Why can't I just reverse it?"
So,
borrowing money and buying back stock,
why don't I raise equity and retire
debt? In theory, it should work, right?
But, what's the problem with being an
over-levered firm trying to issue
shares?
What kind of reception do you think
you're going to get from the market
saying, "I have too much debt. You know
what? I'm going to issue equity." You're
not exactly getting a line of people
saying, "I'd love to buy your stock."
So, why don't you sell your assets and
pay down debt? Think through that as
well. You're in trouble.
How easy is it going to be to get what
you hope you got to get on eBay, right?
Wherever you're trying to sell your
stuff. So, next session when we start,
we're going to start with what happens
when you're over-levered and perhaps the
only thing you have working in your
favor that might allow you to get at
least get to negotiate something that
lets you survive.
So, I will see you next class.